hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and skincare nerd
who doesn't seem to exist below this level
but yeah i have a body and today i'm going
to be talking about some of my best tips
for looking after the skin on your body
if you like nerding out about beauty
click the like the subscribe and
click the nerdification bell
so you don't miss any videos
skincare for your body is like skincare
for your face in a lot of ways but also
not in a lot of other ways my first tip is to pick
actives for your body skin care just like you pick
actives for your face skincare i think a lot of
us use lots of actives on our faces but we sort
of ignore our bodies but there are lots of really
good body products on the market so i thought
i'd tell you about some of the ones that i've
been using lately that i've been really liking
i'm going to start with this video's sponsor
necessaire i talked about their body wash in
my 2019 skincare favorites i really like it
because it's good for cleansing your skin
without stripping it and it's got this really
cute twist top since then i've also tried some
of their leave on products so the body serum and
the body lotion these are the sorts of actives
that you see in face products they're really
minimalist they have really great textures
and they're fragrance free my skin is fine with
fragrance and i personally like having a pleasant
scent especially when i'm using body products but
i know a lot of people can't tolerate fragrance
and it can be hard to find fragrance-free body
products so it's really good that these are
available the textures are also really light which
i love a lot of body products can be really heavy
and sticky and they take ages to sink in these
three all have niacinamide which is one of my
favorite skincare ingredients it's vitamin b3 and
it's really good for sensitive skin there's also
my favorite humectant glycerin which is really
good at keeping your skin hydrated and it's
especially good in cleansers because it helps
prevent your cleanser from stripping your skin
cleansing is one of the harshest steps in your
routine and your natural moisturizing factor
the nmf which is naturally in your skin it's
a natural humectant that can get washed away
so having glycerin in there stops your skin from
getting that tight itchy dry feeling that you can
sometimes get especially if you like hot showers
which i do the serum has hyaluronic acid which
is another really good humectant moisturizer
it can be hard to find body products that have
hyaluronic acid so this is really good for that
on its own it's already really good but if you
pair it with a lotion to lock in the moisture then
it sort of supercharges it and it makes your skin
really really hydrated if you want to try their
products you can use LABMUFFIN10 for 10% off
another brand i really like for body products
is bioderma they have a lot of really hydrating
really soothing products and they use
a lot of patented technologies in them
i've talked about the shower oil before
which is really really lovely in winter
but it's not available in australia but this is
also really good this is a shower gel it's in the
atoderm range which is for really sensitive skin
so this one is fragrance free it's also got lots
of moisturizing humectants and lipids it has
the skin barrier therapy patent which protects
skin from irritating bacteria one of the things i
really like about this is even though it's so good
for sensitive skin it still foams up i really
like foam because it's easier to distribute
and rinse off and so this gives you the option
for foam while still being really really gentle
another brand i really love is qv it's a
bit like the australian version of cerave
i love that they have really large pack
sizes they're really budget friendly and
they have these handy pump bottles
this range is really skin friendly
really gentle it's actually supported
by the eczema association of australia
so if you're into hyaluronic acid i have
to mention the hyaluronic concentrate from
deciem's chemistry brand this is one of their ceo
nicola's favorite products and it's basically just
a pump of goo it has a really nice pump dispenser
this is like a sure way to win me over having a
really handy pump dispenser and this just
pumps straight down which is really nice
this goes for your face as well but i find
it more important for your body when you're
using humectant moisturizers they really shine
when you put occlusives and emollients on top
so a more creamy moisturizer not just a
straight up water-based humectant moisturizer
and having that combination of different types of
moisturizers really helps hydrate your
skin on multiple levels and lock it in
i've also been using the 10balm body lotion
from indeed labs over winter this is just a
really nicely formulated body lotion it works
really well at locking in the humectants
there are also some products that
aren't specifically made for your body
but they're in pretty big pack
sizes and they're reasonably priced
so there's the ordinary glycolic
acid seven percent toning solution
and pixi's glow tonic these acids also double
up really well as deodorants so having a low ph
in your armpits changes the ratio of bacteria
that live there and it's really the bacteria
that causes the smell so they feed off things in
your sweat and turn that into the BO chemicals
you're probably all going to laugh
about how old this bottle is but
this is the paula's choice clear acne
body spray that i've been refilling
this spray is really awesome if you get back acne
because not only is it a spray it actually sprays
upside down i'm sure other brands also have this
but this is actually the only one that i know of
one ingredient that i see in body products but
not in a lot of face products and i wish there
were more is oatmeal oatmeal is in the aveeno
range and it's named after the avenanthramides
which are these really good anti-inflammatory
compounds in oats it's the reason why oatmeal
baths are really good for itchy body
conditions like chickenpox and eczema
now if you want to go really hardcore with
actives on your body like you would with your face
products you can get more intense body products as
well this is from kga body which is an australian
brand it has bakuchiol 0.5% retinol 0.2% and
glycolic acid usually you only find this sort of
thing with clinical brands and as you'd expect it
comes with a clinical brand price tag but if you
work out what the price is per mL it still ends
up being an okay price compared to face products
my next tip is to use face care
products that didn't work on your face
on your body this is like if it broke you out
or if you found a better product since then
it means that you don't waste all your money
you can use it up quickly before it expires and
chances are this will be like the most pampering
your body's ever gotten body skin is generally
more resilient than face skin there's a few extra
layers of dead skin cells in your stratum corneum
there your body skin also can react to different
things so for example things that break out your
face might not break out your body if you did
have a reaction on your face though be really
careful when you're using it on your body try to
avoid sensitive areas and try to avoid broken skin
now let's talk about how to do the
different steps of your routine on your body
you don't need to cleanse your arms
and legs really really thoroughly
this is official dermatologist advice check out
@dermangelo if you haven't already now you should
still be cleansing your smelly bits like
your groin and your armpits and if you get
back acne you should still be cleansing your
back especially if you use hair conditioner
with heavier conditioners these can clog up your
pores and you should still be cleansing your skin
if it's dirty so don't say oh michelle said i
didn't have to clean my skin after like tough
mudder if you have a job where full body hygiene
is really important like if you work in a p4 lab
this doesn't apply to you and obviously we should
still be washing our hands really thoroughly
but for most of us most of the time we
don't have to scrub and scrub our arms
and legs until they're squeaky clean you
are probably doing more harm than good
along the same lines you shouldn't
be showering for too long with too
hot water now i know it's really
nice to have a hot shower sometimes
and i still do it but just know that having that
hot shower having all that water flowing over
your skin is getting rid of your skin's
natural moisturizing factor the natural
humectants in your skin this is actually one
of the big causes of upper back itch in winter
people are having showers and that hot
water is just thumping into the upper back
now for exfoliating your body you can exfoliate
your body just like you do for your face with
the same precautions body skin is a bit tougher
it's a bit thicker than face skin with a few
extra layers of dead skin cells so that means
it's a bit harder to overexfoliate your body
but it can still happen the thicker skin also
means that you get more ingrown hairs and you
can get keratosis pilaris or chicken skin
this is when the dead skin cells block off
the hair follicle to deal with this the
best way is to exfoliate and moisturize
because when your skin is really dry
it doesn't exfoliate itself as well
as well as the chemical exfoliants
i talked about before like glycolic
acid that you use on your face there's
also urea urea shows up in some face
products but it's a lot more common in
body products and it's really good for
exfoliating and moisturizing especially
if you have cracked hands or cracked heels
you can also use a lot of physical exfoliants so
you can use scrubs for example this is one of my
favorites it's the smoothie star breakfast scrub
from soap and glory it smells like maple syrup
you can also make a really effective diy scrub
just by mixing a bit of sugar or salt with oil
you can also use tools like body mitts this is
one from face halo and you can use it wet or dry
when it's dry it's a little bit more efficient
if you're trying to really get into a rough patch
when it's wet it's a lot more gentler and so
that's better for overall areas on your body
there are also exfoliating towels and these are
a lot more popular in asia this is one that i
got from innisfree i've also got one from daiso
which is really good and there's a really popular
one called the italy towel the thing i really like
about these is that it's really good for scrubbing
your back and this is really important if you have
long hair like me where you use lots and lots of
hair conditioner and that hair conditioner tends
to clog your pores the important thing with these
tools is that you need to make sure you let them
dry properly in between uses because it's damp and
it's probably got some of your body products
in it and it's also got your dead skin cells
this is a really good breeding ground for bacteria
and mold so make sure you rinse these properly and
let them dry properly so take them out of
your shower maybe even out of your bathroom
in between uses otherwise if you're using the
dirty tool and you're scrubbing it into your skin
you can actually introduce the bacteria and mold
into your skin and that leads to infections it's
really gross there are case studies on it
so that's one of the reasons i switch from
a sponge on a stick to a body towel for my back
because with the body towel it's a lot easier
to unravel it and rinse it out properly
and then also let it dry out a lot faster
now on the exfoliation topic dark armpits
and knees are normal you are not necessarily
meant to be the same color all over this is a
eurocentric beauty standard you have more skin
where it's folded so your knees your armpits your
elbows and more skin means more melanin and that's
why you have a darker patch there if you have
rough hardened skin or dry scaly patches then
exfoliating and moisturizing can help with that
and yes your skin might get a bit lighter but
if you're a person of color you're not necessarily
meant to have the same color skin all over if your
skin's in a healthy condition and it's symmetrical
then it is normal to have fluctuations in color
there are a few conditions where it isn't normal
and is a reflection of an underlying health issue
and if that's the case you should get it checked
out but otherwise it's just another unrealistic
beauty standard i know if you just start googling
dark armpits and dark knees and dark elbows or
whatever you end up with all these scary health
conditions but that's just a reflection of how
the medical system just doesn't quite
have enough info on skin of color
so let's move on to moisturizing the best
time to apply body moisturizers right after
you step out of the shower when your skin
is still damp when your skin is wet it's
most likely to dry out and so you want to get
moisturizer on there as quickly as you can it's
also really good to seal in that extra moisture
and so that humectant can grab onto extra water
it's also a good idea to track your moles
especially if you have lighter skin or if you
get a lot of sun exposure there's a really good
acronym for spotting suspicious moles it's abcde
so if you have a mole that's asymmetric with
a fuzzy border if it's got uneven color if
it's bigger than a pencil eraser or if it's been
changing in appearance then these are all features
that you should get checked out so you should go
to a doctor and ask them to look at your mole and
maybe take a biopsy in australia it's recommended
that you have an annual all-over body mole check
and usually your gp can do this there are apps
that can help you track moles and these can be
really useful but don't rely on them 100%
because it's still pretty new technology
it doesn't necessarily work for all sorts of
cancerous moles or all skin types for your body
of course we also need to talk about sun
protection this is especially the case if
you're exfoliating with alpha hydroxy acids which
can make your skin more sensitive to the sun
or if you're using really expensive
anti-aging actives on your skin
it's a waste of money if you're not also
protecting your skin from further damage
so check the uv index to see if
you need to protect your skin i
have another video on upf clothing and how to
pick normal clothes that protect you from uv
if you're using sunscreen make sure
you use enough so the recommendation
is one teaspoon for the front of your
torso one for the back of your torso
one for each limb and one for
your face and ears and neck
so i hope you found this video useful share your
best body tips in the comments if you liked it
you can click the like and subscribe for more
videos like this you can follow me on instagram
@labmuffinbeautyscience and check out my blog
for more nerdy beauty content see you next time